welcome to this video playing really
Hendrix Prince panic I'm having black
again do I always have black against him
it really feels like that I know i'm
giving up lots of time here yeah i have
six black games against him and only one
white game yeah ok this cuff deserve was
giving away some time but I was really
curious about this I always have like it
for some reason ok we have a um an
Italian game which is what we would be
normally have he does not play the
reuleaux pass so what about Bishop e6
here hmm now I can prepare that maybe
yeah wide range of possibilities in
those kind of positions I wonder if I
play but should be six takes take screen
b3f got Quincy ate everything else
failed so going to try to exchange this
there are many plans available for both
sides it's a rather flexible way of
playing yeah I can just take it yeah
come on the keep it simple method and
now play rook e8 Bishop f8 ultimately
going for d5 sorry for the song but I
need something to drink here if I a fair
I don't want him to play a 6 i'm going
to stop that yeah he's got some pressure
on you five but still I feel like next
move um I'm settled settled let's say
I'm ready let's use simple English here
I'm ready to play d5 like Ed 525 and
the e5 pawn isn't a big issue I mean his
d3 porn is just as weak or even weaker I
think okay it's taking some time maybe
queen bee three those kind of ideas this
whole opposition does not feel very
ambitious for white but I'm really
totally used to play this from from the
black side okay d 5 85 95 he might have
nice GL on these slides night f5 as a
possible move okay i can i can play g6
Bishop g7
okay night h fri am is this a move
threatening the simpler night takes g6
maybe yeah maybe um okay but now Bishop
g7 is really really useful and maybe
Queen d7 Queenie six or something then
it's got 95 again yeah this is kind of
positions are I'm not very young wow
this is not a move I expected
okay Knights e5 e6 and so on I thought
back to is six mmm
I can also just kick the night but ok
let's let's start with with this
regrouping first night to e6b for night
eserve c7 and c6 maybe so 97 and c6 he
might have D for later it's 94 move here
or not then taking with the pole and c6
I'm not sure not sure very very complex
porn structures that arise an
interesting choice i'm not not sure but
i think that there are ideas yeah i
thought c6 and the night on b6 is really
it's not clear that this is a good piece
really not okay so is he going to play
he maybe play here maybe we'll play 35
Ori five
well how difficult Wow dad aside didn't
think about it all interesting yeah he
wants to get the d5 square which might
be successful but I can't drop back
actually and now get i get c5 and down
on the clock which is not good but he
saw one minutes ahead
seems he didn't consider 96 very much as
it often happens you don't look at the
retreat's not that or let's say the kind
of move that just takes the last the
last move back but I thought it was a
good idea the night on c5 no really has
a good position night coming over to be
32 which I probably will retreat it
again yeah I cannot take in as highly
honey taking is really helping em so I'm
going to go back again yes that was
clear not much I could do however be 43
years possibly good okay is preventing
that okay I this is really ugly yeah but
I'd really don't see I cannot do without
the movie night f form to trade this one
ugly stuff yeah you played this very
nicely here on the queenside
the only thing I have in my favor I mean
not like favoring black but this that a
five is a slight weakness but that's
absolutely the only thing not good not
good at all this disposition and it's
not invading their
Queen Queen B 7s coming so only chance
some some British a direct counter
attack check threatening rook h2 maybe
check check check check
check Jack forfeit I know i forfeited
with two seconds I really caught up here
but of course this was deserved with
Tory wow that was interesting so maybe
this this pawn structure wasn't good
after all for black or maybe it's maybe
c6 maybe this is not not right yeah I
knew that this is something that might
might blow up in my face this this night
CD phone but i wasn't sure i mean the
conservative way to play it is just this
one intending c6 which shouldn't be that
terrible I mean let's say b4 c6 I might
retreat him yeah this is a slight
advantage for wide the probably is still
see for seems like a strange length to
me but maybe I'm maybe I need to play it
differently ah ok yeah this this is the
way to play it I have to do this ok ok
and this is much better in comparison
because the night here it looks at
especially b6 which means that after c 6
i'm going to trade the night this is a
very important difference in yeah this
should be ok now let's say i don't know
what white should do here um what kind
of motion won't play
hmmm not not really not sure what you
should do maybe not not saying that his
verse or anything I just don't exactly
know what white should play like what is
a good improving move here let's just
make a zero move here then c6 is a big
difference as now I can actually oops I
can actually take this so that there is
no night IAM and i don't think that that
this structure is a big issue it's still
better for my jam b4 b5 it's nothing
terribly serious but still yeah okay
it's it's tricky maybe why it retains a
small advantage here or I shouldn't put
anything on d foil I mean this is
possible like here I should do something
totally different if what about let's
say what about this and go for f5 maybe
be four and five let's try something
else yeah this is this is not bad
problem yeah this this is this is
probably better him I have a clamp-on
deform so that's not coming and they
have some play here yeah this I like
more relief instead of putting something
on deform yeah nicely played by white
thanks for watching